newly obtained police body cam footage
seems to contradict the account from one
of the men charged in ahmad arberi's
killing
william bryan goes by rhodey recorded
gregory and travis mcmichael
chasing arbury back in february now
brian's lawyer says
his client was quote never more than a
witness to arbury's death
but omar villafranca has the video that
suggests he was more involved
you're a pacifier coming through not
necessarily this body camera footage
obtained by our jacksonville station
w-j-a-x shows roddy bryan talking to
police
moments after ahmad arbury's death
brian recorded that video of the
february 23
shooting it was posted online months
later
bringing national attention to the case
and leading police to arrest him
as well as gregory and travis mcmichael
now brian and the mcmichaels face
several charges in the killing
including felony murder they have all
pleaded not guilty
and have been denied bail by a judge i
truthfully need to be cleared of this
because i had nothing to do with it
before his arrest
brian said his reputation was being
smeared
but in the body cam footage he told
police this
i pulled out of my driveway i was going
to try to block him
he was going all around it and i made a
few moves at him you know
we think he's an active participant i
spoke to cobb county prosecutor jesse
evans for 48 hours
he said there's evidence to suggest that
brian hit arbory with his truck
while trying to box him in this is how
brian's attorney
kevin goff responded he's never been
more than a witness
to this shooting there's dents on the
truck
there is no evidence that mr brian
did anything improper with his vehicle
in a statement responding to the new
video
arbory's mother wanda cooper jones said
in part
this man stood feet away from where my
son lay shot to death
and seems to brag about his part he and
all involved
must be held accountable to the fullest
extent of the law
for cbs this morning i'm omar
villafranca
now we reached out to brian's lawyer for
a response to that body cam video he's
the lawyer who said there had been
no evidence of brian's involvement but
he did not respond at this time we also
contacted the georgia bureau of
investigation which is handling the
arbory case
a spokesperson there did not deny the
authenticity of the footage but told us
that the gbi
is not sure how wjx got it
and the spokesperson also stressed that
the agency did not release the video
itself
because the case as you know is
currently being litigated
well still it's another example of how
important it is to have video
video proof in these particular cases
because it's telling a different story
than what he's
doing and you know the um the mod
arberry's attorneys
said from the very beginning that
william roddy was more involved than he
was leading everybody to believe
that that tape certainly raises a lot of
questions i would call it evidence makes
me wonder if the lawyer for bryant uh
o'brien knew that that tape was out
there he may not have
yeah it's his own testimony that he was
in a sense in essence
an act of participant